your children may think we are safe now
but had they heard her crying and they
feel the sting of reduce
they will
and she will come for the
no don't know all right so we're here
talking about this film in an actual
haunted hotel yes we have to talk we
have to start off by asking you guys
like have any of you ever had a haunted
experience have you ever been in like a
haunted place and gone and then said oh
wow then they had one here actually last
night really no it sounds silly but it
really i went to the LBJ suite which is
this beautiful suite that we got the
chance to just be in for the day and i
to use the ladies room or the bat and
it's gorgeous gorgeous gigantic it must
be the presidential suite bathroom with
this bathtub and if you've seen the
movie there's this whole bathtub
sequence that's terrifying yes and so i
was going about my business from the
bathroom and and i was looking around
and it was it was it centered by this
beautiful old stained glass I was
singing God if I wasn't believer this
would be really creepy for me but you
know I'm not I didn't have any creepy
experiences and just then the light
above me it's hard to flickering and I
thought well that's a fluke someone's
probably using hair dryer in the other
room and then it kept happening really
quick in Iran and I thought it was so
strange because I didn't I hadn't had
any of those experiences but it felt
funny to me that the movie was not gonna
let me be without having at least one
yes and and I've had it here in this
hotel in Austin so it was pretty fitting
well it is fitting do you feel like good
patrician when you do a film like this
do you feel like you're sort of you're
more aware of kind of things around you
in your life that that shouldn't be
happening to you yeah especially the
sound I mean we we've in case of mayor
now you know we've grown up with this
with this entity that she is real for us
this is how they kept us home when we
were little and as you grow older you
still believe in her but somehow you
know with the day-to-day you you don't
listen you're not focused and I think
that's what she that's what she did so
these should in this film make make you
much more aware and I still I mean we
shut it off
how long ago and I'm still so much there
is not one night that I go to bed that I
don't think of her that's interesting
because
is a real curse this is sad that that is
real and culture Raymond goodwill talked
about like how is this you know what is
the in terms of what are you told
growing up like is this a big sort of
eventually the only known survivor of
other have you don't know abduction I
was a child
and she took me and I escaped she wasn't
human
oh you told us again I heard you talking
about this woman that if you go out that
she's going to get you she's going to
drown you and take your life Oh
steal your soul that's what they tell
you but we all hear her it's no I mean
right and there's been lots of sightings
of law and order
New Mexico Mexico California taxes she's
everywhere everywhere once when and
that's interesting Michael talk about
creating the look of La Llorona you know
where do you go to but and who do you
speak to in terms of sort of bringing
her to life on screen well you know we
were extremely lucky to have as one of
our producers the master of horror
himself James Wan and I've been a James
Wan fan for so long he's the ultimate
monster maker so you know I loved
monster makeup as a kid I actually
thought I wanted to get into like
effects like makeup you know when I was
younger and so to be able to work with
the teenage monster deserves a shout out
he did our yeah makeup and he's a rock
star and he really defined that look and
to be able to collaborate with James to
pitch him ideas to show him different
looks and get his guidance was
extraordinary
to get these insights on you know what
what works so it works with scares what
you know getting something that's punchy
but memorable it was amazing and you
know I was just you know it was just it
was a surreal experience as an
incredible experience did any of you
have any of you ever met somebody who
claims to have seen like oh oh yes yeah
of course oh yeah what's the experience
what did they say well I I think I heard
that you don't know when I was a kid I
think my brothers I heard that you don't
know when we were a kid so we lived in
Mexico and in this place where there was
this all abandoned casino and you know
like your own and that's where she
stayed that's where she lived and we
hurt her we scream every night so it's
it's not something that you you know you
you go and you meet somebody in you say
oh I'm going to let your honor oh my
father saw her or Mike my grandmother
heard her so she is a part of our
culture she's not a myth she is very
real to us when I was growing up there
were it was two kids that were around a
lake and a part they were found dead and
everyone immediately that's true we all
heard the stories all the time
especially when the park yes if they
were our Park that meant the immediately
was Laird and Raymond talk about your
character and sort of what he brings to
the table because he's different he's
not you know your conventional priest
that comes in and sort of does blessings
like how is he different and and well
he's different in the sense that he's an
ex-priest so he has one foot in the
world of religion and then he's a good
on that oh he's a shaman a mystic and he
helps people deal with the supernatural
whereas the church will kind of dismiss
it or not move quickly enough to aid
them I'm kind of the guy that they go to
because I'm like oh yeah this is real
and then you know and we have to deal
with this you know I don't want to tell
you too much of what happens but I'm
amazing in the movie
you